he latches with us in Jacksonville
Florida hi Elijah how can I help a mr.
Ramsey how you doing today better than I
deserve
what's up basically I just graduated
college couple months ago and I got a
full-time job at the place that I was
interning at it's the perfect place for
the degree that I got but I really think
that kind of being drawn towards the
real estate industry I got my real
estate license while I was in school and
I just kind of watching the device and
how I can start to work my way into the
real estate industry get some experience
while I still have this full-time jobs
and potentially just start going to real
estate full-time I just want some advice
on how to kind of make that transition
and get experience while I'm still
working full time so you went to school
for years to get a degree in a career
field that you started a couple of
months ago and you're already wanting to
leave it but I still kind of enjoy it
but after actually you know like being
in the office and getting to see how the
business is actually run I'm not sure if
it's what I want to do a full-time
personal life how long have you been
doing it long you been oh wait how long
have you been in the office how long you
been out school I've been out of school
I graduated in late April so I've been
full-time for about two three months
I've been at the office since February
what do you do it's a it's a I work with
a lot of CFPs financial advising I got
my degree in financial planning and
finance and what is it that you thought
it was going to be that it's not I
wasn't very surprised that I just
thought I would probably enjoy the work
for you need to just get a little more
fulfillment out of it after doing it for
a while
you never done it's not that you've done
it for three months yeah that's not very
that was five years I don't really know
if I want you to go that distance on me
I mean I just feel like I'm being drawn
towards a real finish I just want to
kind of want to start she doesn't get
experience and see if that is what I
actually want to do
okay well you're gonna struggle at
whatever you do if you don't give it
more than three months to figure it out
it takes a little bit more time I mean
you spent four years on this goal and
then in three months you're abandoning
that goal because and using phrases like
I'm being drawn to like by a mysterious
force no I
it just sounds real impulsive the way
you're describing what the calendar of
what's going on I mean if you've been in
there three years and you hated every
minute of it I don't I don't want you to
spend your whole life doing something
you hate that that's not my goal but you
know you need to really kind of think
through what was it that drew you to the
financial planning world and then what
is it that's turning you off because
it's not logical that you spent this
much time working on something knowing
what it was and then after three months
just decide you don't like it so anyway
the way to move into the real estate
business would be if you've answered
those questions for yourself it doesn't
affect me but if you've answered those
questions maturely for yourself then
with a way to move into it would be
part-time and get a broker that would
allow you to get your license and place
your like you said your had your license
already place your license with a broker
and start working part-time the good
news about residential real estate is
most people look at houses when they're
not at work and so your most premium
times showing houses and working real
estate deals or evenings and weekends so
it really doesn't interfere that having
a full-time job doesn't interfere that
much with doing real estate I mean
there's sometimes you do stuff during
the day but the vast majority of your
actual eyeball-to-eyeball knee kept and
he kept with a potential buyer or seller
is on an evening or a weekend so you can
do a lot of that stuff and build up your
experience your book of business and not
have to go from making money to making
nothing for six months and starve out
because it usually takes about six
months in residential business to start
actually getting closings and making a
living and so forth and you know but
there's a good news there's a lot of
your financial planning
training will help you in the academic
side of this I'm sure you probably
picked up some marketing classes in that
degree as well those will help you
obviously the the financial parts of you
know helping someone look at a different
finance plan for a home or whatever will
help you you've got a you know a good
base knowledge of all of that but I just
don't want you to sit down and I'm gonna
challenge you that you you've spent four
years working on something and then
three months later have decided it's not
okay that just doesn't ring well and you
need to think that throw that part of
this through it could be that where
you're doing it the group of people
you're doing the financial planning with
you don't like you don't like their
process it feels slimy to you you went
into this to serve people you don't feel
like people are the center of this that
numbers are or you went into this to
serve numbers and these folks you're
working with or two people or in it I
don't know but you need to think about
is that the place and the group you're
doing it with is that the particular
activity you plugged into and so on and
that that's what I would try to figure
out so hey thanks for the call